[Music]
all right in spoiled brat news submitted
by jazz hands a teen claims she has to
live like a peasant after her mom cut
her monthly allowance yo okay question
is this monthly like Taiwanese royalty
allowing oh yeah their regular allowance
I know some [ __ ] that get like
it's unfairly held I know it I know that
ah yeah not far I said that's why I said
I know it
Kaji 3000 just be a daughter I mean I
knew some kid I knew some kids like hey
yeah I need some kids like that she was
crazy
I have a friend his ex-girlfriend had a
monthly allowance of clothes there was
something around like 10 G's and then
she was telling me it got cut because
now that she graduated she has to now
work now so it got cut I don't know what
it started and she still has it right it
got cut the six grand a month
oh he still get that [ __ ] the first not
including that's separate from her
apartment and her car waiting people did
pay all that yeah and then the six
friends just done the play money Wow you
know we can hear as much as we want but
we know what she had it you know what
these are you know what they don't have
them um you have I want to try to have
love to you trying to make she honey
wait great
boobies to so I don't know she had
everything isn't that babies and parents
people not real is it five grand a month
present money to these rich people
though it is I mean this girl's 1500
teen five thousand a month
damn that goes a long way when her 15
five thousand a month I didn't have it
at that age she why we're all peasants
she go on on like Twitter and started
ranting like my [ __ ] parents
asking some on consoles it's also full
hooker with
os also care about children snowfall
fatality Oh Oh ma'am 15 hours own high
school I was I was bootlegging CDs and
selling candy for money so I could buy
like fresh air forces and [ __ ] because I
didn't want my parents buying like
paying for the expensive clothes like
all the name-brand pride
yeah dude so I would go I just didn't
want them spending money on like
expensive name-brand [ __ ] and you know
going to public school they judge you
you know so I wanted to shine John I
wanted the air forces so I'll go to
smart final hour buy boxes of candy and
be slinging them for like a dollar like
Snickers and M&Ms during class you're so
stupid I did the same thing you saw the
salt draws I made way more yeah you
right
yeah what are you a decent human being
you sell candy and elementary drugs is
what you upgrade to kids of you I didn't
recommend it I'm just saying that's true
usually what happens in the hood it's
just it's just basic economics is true
yeah but all those people smoking weed
though guess what the Candyman was
that's like the girls cow who sold in
front of the dispensary oh yeah
sold out damn so that's 15 year-olds
Beverly Hills breath as her mom calls
her Oh her mom keen on propagated the
Bratz bed thank you thank you and so
okay so the daughter took her mom to dr.
Phil we met now she has to live like a
peasant she's just trying to be like
whoa Vic yep no no kiss me outside oh
yeah respect her name bad baby
Danielle bruh goalie all right bad baby
yeah she [ __ ] owns an Italian
meatball sub place the Batali special
sorry sure you guys the 30-second clip
like the promo of her episode of Rat
King she looks old for 16 how's about
the same yeah
she was young 15 you buddy she got a
different you buddy got me twisted going
at me you got me here we go I have
raised it Beverly Hills brat her
allowance is crazy giving this child
fast dogs about this insane
I'm barely living her attitude how does
she treat people like peasants he's
entitled by the time I was your age
myself oh my god you start with a job
people are cracking up oh my god you
know what's sad though they built that
though they built her she's you can't
[ __ ] it she's 15 her parents created
that world that's what she was telling
her mom - it's like I was raised in this
environment I don't know anything else
just [ __ ] old for 15 though dude
pretty girl oh yeah she but she looks
like she's like mid-20s you me she was
pretty no thank you
no she's 15 well vicki was cute though
oh she is cute though Oh cute if you
[ __ ] saw her around the same no no
she was like the Mona Lisa right there
right here masturbate to the Mona Lisa
every day was a kid also the mango peach
I was artistic as [ __ ] yeah yes I did no
for real I'm pretty sure you masturbated
of food don't [ __ ] mind
he was in 1439 food stupid food yeah
banana peel yeah Lisa's [ __ ] banging
yeah I did oh I know it was so specific
like he picked the right look check it
out to be able to go off on a tangent
real quick when I first is we don't do
that here when I discovered jacking off
when I was like you know and I was like
like late junior high early high school
wish I do so curious cuz I loved it so
much I found this website it's called
jacking world.com one had tips and
special things to try for you when
you're jerking off and someone was like
yo you should try jogging off with a
banana peel there's like natural it's
like naturally lubricated yeah it's like
that's so cool cuz it's all it's all
like you know slippery in there yeah you
just jism to it and you thought oh like
wow
I got three on your skin these smell of
banana peel is oh really and then after
you jack off you split dude get those
while and I'll choke sorry girl jacking
off I feel like what's happening is
every was like oh look at his bug she
doesn't deserve it and it's like you
know us peasants we love to look at
royalty and being like [ __ ] them I like
to watch them fall love to have like the
little Kardashian clan came up like
crazy cuz they were laughing at them but
they're laughing a bank I've always said
that I've never laughed at that
no I laugh at him a lot but now I want
to go back do you think well Vicki is
actually cute I think she's actually
pretty I think she's pretty but ugly she
well you're entitled to your [ __ ]
[Music]
dodged a bullet we asked those girls
just complaining and then dr. Phil ends
up telling the mom like alright well you
need to stop throwing money at your
daughter yeah no [ __ ] dr. Phil yeah
everybody can get that same [ __ ]
advice dude you're not a doctor you [ __ ]
that was pretty funny now I love that
she was saying that because now dr. Phil
Santa he's gonna do should the mom
should drop the allowance from 5,000 to
1,000 [ __ ] $20 thousand dollars a
month at 15 dude guys been nice yeah and
then dr. Phil is also telling the mom
like she needs to get her own jobs like
and then she started saying like well I
babysit but I don't get paid for
babysitting and then dr. feels like no
she needs to go out into the real world
like that's not
I mean that doesn't even make some real
[ __ ] fill at 15 [ __ ] years old
yeah you're not allowed to put it in
your workout 14 you just need a permit
from that family they should just be
like yo she should be getting a [ __ ]
4.0 on her [ __ ] grades and leave it
at that like have her be an extra I
agree with that like if you're rich
right and you work to a point where you
don't necessarily want to put your kids
through that right like they would they
don't have to work like at least make it
so that they value the money they're
getting you know I'm saying so it's like
either get grades or do chores or you
know pay her for the babysitting like
what would be a terrible future period I
want my kids to grow up and have the
same problems I have I'm gonna keep the
beauty supply store then it'll work
there I must have been dating you
because I wanted to work so bad I was
begging my parents like please I wanna
meet you never let me work I just wanted
to work and then get money for it you
mean because I would have to work in my
parents door but no money I would just
like for there to be money somehow
that's why I got a real job because when
I was working on my family's restaurant
I felt I felt silly being like I'm gonna
help and then and then get money from
them you know saying I was like I'm
gonna help the business I'm gonna go go
get a job outside of the restaurant and
bring in that money to the fingers a
[ __ ] good dude damn I was just
begging for anything else like you I've
been here for [ __ ] ten hours can I
get like a snicker can I get something
you know I mean like give me anything
and then finally the day came they gave
me $20 to work ten hours a day
wow that's great what about the house
that you live in no percent I didn't
beat you today aren't you lucky it was
[ __ ] awesome I loved making money
yeah it was fun I don't know how they
see it as a burden like I don't have any
friends that were like I don't want a
job they just never worked ever yeah I
mean like that chick has never probably
done a dish or anything so mom she she
learned that from like people are
peasants and all that that [ __ ] didn't
come from her head other other rich
people other rich people and like no one
no one put her in check you know I'm
saying like when you're you're the
daughter the only but she's probably the
only daughter and the family too so I
mean she's the baby and like so like I
feel like the parents have been telling
her since beginning you get whatever you
want
do whatever you want princess yeah the
princess I mean real talk though if I
had a lot of money I wouldn't want my
kid to work oh I want my kid to [ __ ]
you better want to trim bellies and so
yeah but I can teach him in other
different ways you never even that'd be
like what's another way God like let's
start building a business or something
what are you really into let's start you
know the difference between that is it's
like when when somebody gets to like for
example when somebody gets to work and
likes like class class jobs that they
wouldn't be able to work before you
actually get to become a better business
owner that you can understand so it's
like if you have no sympathy for the
janitor and what they do then you're
just like these people are dispensable
working you have to you can't replace
experience no theory can replace it like
that even one of my parents own the
business joking aside like he made me
work another job so he he wanted me to
understand what it's like to go through
the process to have to apply and then
work for somebody that's not your family
because technically I could get away
with whatever but when I'm working
somewhere else I have to do my best and
show how good I am at that and you have
to work with people you don't like that
yeah like if you have a stupid-ass
manager is a smart manager you're like
oh man there's a huge different that's
what will make a better business owner
it's kind of like empathy when you're
kids right so like like when I was at
the church they would send us to Mexico
like it like the you know those are like
the beginning mission trips you could
tell your kid as much as you want you're
blessed to have what you have but they
need to go experience with with they
don't hand see it we got to get malaria
for a week Tijuana water and [ __ ]
diarrhea never you just got to go to
[ __ ] Holland raise and get my hottest
wings ever
oh my god they spit up in front of a
group of people that's what he did
yesterday make sure you watch the
episode of send food so you can watch
that happen
it is crazy or you could just be rich as
[ __ ] spoiled kids and say [ __ ] it
that's the world's problem not my true
like and and here's the thing like okay
so like you know we know we're all gonna
be rich right so it's not hope so
ya know it's a fact know so it's a fact
so I normally [ __ ] Richard I know I
know and it's like but I debated being
like maybe I'm just gonna tell my kids
were broken to the
10:04 sure truman show dude yeah yeah to
1018 all the way through dude I'm
talking about I'm kind of look put like
[ __ ] dirt and chimneys sit on my face
I would look like that do for me the
part is chiminey chim chim musical ships
[Music]